armez-vous une personne c'est
particulièrement distingué
son nom est arrivé plusieurs fois
jusqu'à mon oreille jouer un héros de
l'époque mérovingienne lors d'une
exposition c'est l'expérience immersive
proposée dans le monde de Clovis au
Musée d'archéologie nationale de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour découvrir
l'époque du premier Moyen-Âge le public
est invité à interpréter un personnage
fictif via son smartphone l'énergie
quand darchius la bile bâtild la
courageuse Geneviève ou l'intelligent
Médard on a tout à fait voulu s'inspirer
des codes du jeu de rôle du jeu vidéo
des escape game pour attirer un public
un peu plus jeune par rapport à celui
qu'on a l'habitude de d'accueillir ici
au Musée d'archéologie nationale
ce public voilà les adolescents les
jeunes adultes c'est un public qui de
manière générale fréquente moins les
musées parce qu'il est très exigeant il
a besoin peut-être aussi qu'on s'adapte
à ses attentes le visiteur choisit les
différentes étapes de la naissance à la
mort de son personnage point de prestige
et de richesse sont gagnés en fonction
de la pertinence des réponses les objets
exposés illustrent l'histoire du héros
incarnée comme ce dilemme crucial dans
l'existence de Médard que je fasse un
choix un choix de vie est-ce que je veux
rester à la cour avec ben voilà le grand
monde on illustre ça avec les bijoux de
la reine aregonde où est-ce que je veux
plutôt suivre le destin de la reine bah
tilde dont la tunique de moniale est
présentée juste à côté et est-ce que je
veux entrer au monastère chez une
exposition qui est c'est bien expliqué
et aussi ce qui est bien c'est qu'on
peut choisir son personnage et c'est un
peu nous le le personnage pour les
adultes et bah il y avait les textes
sont suffisamment clairs et suffisamment
court pour que ce soit agréable c'est
roméovingiens attire environ 1000
visiteurs chaque week-end le monde de
Clovis est à retrouver jusqu'au 22 mai
2023 au Musée d'archéologie nationale de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye